question très importante est ce que vous
avez déjà pris des faits c'est quand
vous êtes vous êtes un enfant parent non
voilà enfin voilà ce que c'est un débat
cseries oublier qu'ils m'adressent c'est
un débat qui revient très régulièrement
à l'assemblée faut-il interdire la
fessée une nouvelle proposition de loi
devrait être examiné dans les prochains
jours et c'est un sujet du cisr infos de
france 2 on regarde et on s'en parle
juste après mettre une fessée une gif ou
tenir des propos humiliants à son enfant
ces violences éducatives aujourd'hui
tolérer en france pourrait bientôt être
interdite après son annulation en 2017
pour des raisons de procédure une
nouvelle loi anti fessée sera présenté
le 29 novembre prochain l'assemblée
il s'agit là d'une mesure pédagogique
aucune sanction pénale n'est prévu pour
les parents les porteurs de cette loi
espèrent surtout favoriser une prise de
conscience aujourd'hui 85 pour cent des
français utilisent encore ces pratiques
la france comme la belgique l'italie la
république tchèque et le royaume-uni
fait partie des rares pays de l'union
européenne à ne pas avoir encore voté
l'interdiction des violences éducatives
alors pour information aujourd'hui je
sens qu'on applaudit avec des gens qui
sont contre la fessée
aujourd'hui c'est la journée
internationale des droits de l'enfant
pour pour information si elle est
adoptée cette loi la france serait le
55e pays enfin interdisant les violences
éducatives ordinaires ce qu'on appelle
donc la fessée ferait partie de ça
qu'est ce que vous en pensez caroline
l'a fait c'est ce que vous qui avez des
enfants qui sont petit d'ailleurs vous
avez recours parfois dans des moments un
peu de fatigue de détresse de
je-ne-sais-quoi jamais reçu de fessée
jamais donné je pense que c'est aussi un
truc voilà qui ce qui se transmet moi je
suis totalement contre
j'interviens même quand je vois dans la
rue des mamans qui c'est queen un peu
qui donne une fessée et je comprends
très bien le le caractère demandé sur
soudain delà de la fessée mais moi je
pars du principe qu'on ne fait pas un
enfant se compterait pas un adulte si je
me fâche avec vous je te maraver je vais
très très mal parce que là on va contrer
dans une escalade de la violence s'est
restreint un peu d'éducation et de base
après j'en ai pas du tout reçu moi dans
mon enfance vous imaginez bien que je me
suis rattrapé à l'âge adulte avec
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est formidable c'est que je
m'attendais pas à ce qu'elle dira
reviennent sur le sujet et à ce moment
là on n'a pas eu de plan sur le visage
de 10 me mohamed traitement effondré
jimmy pour revenir à la fessée pour les
enfants des médicaments qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ces de ces mesures qui a
parce que on dit c'est de la
maltraitance mais où commence la
maltraitance est ce qu une tape sur les
doigts parce qu' un enfant tout en bas
âge s'approche d'une prise électrique ou
parce qu'on a eu peur parce qu'il a
traversé la route et que une petite tape
sur la couche je ne sais pas est ce que
tu à proscrire quoi qu'il arrive je
pense que cette mesure va dans le bon
sens on reproche souvent aux
gouvernements et aux qui se succèdent à
chaque problème une loi une interdiction
là on explique que le but est
pédagogique qu'il n'y aura pas forcément
de sanction il y aura pas un policier
d'achat mais au rang mais pour obama
différé mais on veut légiférer parce que
on explique que comme on est un des
derniers pays à ne pas l'avoir fait et
qu'il faut considérer que une fessée
n'est pas une sanction éducative on
n'éduque pas un enfant lui mettant une
fessée
car à mon sens on va pas dire que mettre
une fessée c'est un de la maltraitance
mais on arrive petit à petit vers un
modèle où on va cautionner ça à l'époque
on cautionnait que le professeur puisse
donner des tapes ou punir sévèrement
avec des circuits en porte à porte en
porte corporelle pardon les enfants on
trouve ça absolument scandaleux
désormais imaginer nous adultes on rate
un créneau on fait cuire trop 2d pas
trop longtemps on fait une petite bêtise
est ce que nous on nous mettrait une
fessée non tard on va dans le mauvais
sens l'éducation ne passent pas par les
violence quelle qu'elle soit et je pense
qu'il faut aller dans le bon sens et ne
pas voir ça comme un énième interdiction
est de se dire qu'au contraire c'est de
la pédagogie vous compreniez compte
qu'on ne veuille pas banaliser la même
la plus petite fessée du monde parce que
tolérance zéro va dire c'est vraiment
juste pour donner un symbole et faire
comprendre aux gens qu'on ne tape pas un
enfant et que ça peut commencer par
d'abord une petite fessée
la fois d'après il ne m'écoute pas mais
je vais lui mettre une claque et puis
peut-être que ça va être quotidien et ça
va être récurrent moi j'ai passé pour la
marâtre mais juste pas totalement contre
la haine
je montrerai cessé après il ya une
différence entre la fessée cul nu ou
vraiment on y va franco et la petite
tape sur les fesses pourrait dire
attends ça fait trois fois que je te
l'expliquer tu comprends toujours pas
donc je mets une petite tape je fais une
grosse différence à gaza
dk tival nuls on est d'accord non bah
forcément ça dépend des impôts s'ils ont
la chance d'avoir des enfants qui sont
physiquement très calme et bien je punis
mon enfant quand il fait des bêtises en
soins il m'écoute pas eu dans un âge
c'est assez difficile à 5 ans et donc je
le mets pas mettre à 15
mais c'est vrai petit enfant petit
problème mais voilà je le mets au coin
ça dure deux minutes
ensuite je lui explique pourquoi je les
miens au coin et comprend ça une plus
grande valeur que de le taper c'est un
acte l'enfant devra vraiment ça comme
une agression mais la violence est
exactement comme je pense contre 15 ans
il verra pas au coin un chat
c'est la responsabilité des parents tout
ça c'est pas pour l'état moi j'suis la
dégénération dessins animés
ultraviolence pas pour ça qu'on a
déclenché une troisième guerre mondiale
n'ont donc ça ne sert à rien d'imposer
aux parents à nouveau voyager faire et
des nouvelles lois sur le sujet en tout
cas une loi pour interdire la fessée on
a posé la question de téléspectateurs
est ce que vous êtes pour ou est-ce que
vous êtes contre et vous êtes contre
cette loi en tout cas à 77% ce qui veut
pas dire que vous soyez pour la fessée
bien sûr mais c'est sur l'aspect légal
il faut aussi le dire aux animaux que la
fessée est interdite on n'a pas le droit
[Applaudissements]